let's talk about sustainability you've
probably come across the word
sustainable at some point in your life
if i decided to continue to talk for the
rest of this video without taking a
breath you might tell me mia that's just
not sustainable
in this scenario which i obviously would
never even dream of attempting i'd be
depleting the oxygen in my lungs without
replacing it
using resources faster than they could
be replenished is not sustainable
but what does sustainability really mean
well the word sustain means to maintain
or to hold
so sustainability is the ability of
something to be maintained over a period
of time
in environmental science when we talk
about sustainability we're talking about
the ability of the earth's systems to
survive and adapt to changing
environmental conditions and maintain
the health of ecosystems
it's like a delicate balance where each
process doesn't take too much or produce
too much so that all the other processes
can keep on going and theoretically when
all these processes are doing their jobs
this balance could last forever
but some things that humans do can
disrupt this balance
let's take a look at an example
in the early years of the united states
enslaved and free farm workers in the
american south planted or were forced to
plant cotton
a plant that needs to use the nitrogen
in the soil to survive but when they
planted cotton in the same fields year
after year the cotton plants would
deplete the nitrogen levels in the soil
this constant depletion of nitrogen was
not sustainable and the cotton crop
suffered
in the early 20th century agricultural
scientist and inventor george washington
carver suggested that farmers could
alternate between growing cotton and
growing nitrogen fixing plants like
peanuts or sweet potatoes
this is a more sustainable way of
farming as the nitrogen-fixing plants
would replace the nitrogen that the
cotton plants took out of the soil
since then we've discovered a way of
putting nitrogen back into the soil
using chemically synthesized fertilizers
but sustainability is more complicated
than just replacing depleted resources
when farmers use too much fertilizer or
use poor methods of fertilizer
application all that fertilizer can run
off into neighboring waterways
this excess nitrogen in the water could
cause a lot of algae to grow
the thing about algae is that when it
grows too rapidly it also dies rapidly
and the microbes that decompose the
algae hog the available oxygen in the
water which makes it difficult for other
organisms living in the water to breathe
so when the fertilizer runoff causes too
much algae to grow it creates an
imbalance in the ecosystem and harms the
other organisms that rely on the
dissolved oxygen in the water
so the addition of too much fertilizer
is also unsustainable
but how could a farmer know whether
they're using fertilizer sustainably
well they could look out for
environmental indicators
environmental indicators are basically
when the earth tells us
hey there's something unsustainable in
this ecosystem
but instead of just telling us that
straight out it tells us in a variety of
clues
for our farmer environmental indicators
can be things like the amount of
dissolved oxygen in the water the
biological diversity in the area or even
how much algae grows in nearby water
sources
the series of events triggered by
fertilizer pollution could deplete the
amount of oxygen in the water so species
that live in the water that require a
lot of oxygen to survive could begin to
die off
these species are called indicator
species
because they're known to survive in very
specific circumstances
spotting these species is an indication
that there is a lot of oxygen in the
water if these species are absent then
that would be an indication that the
pollution has reduced the amount of
dissolved oxygen in the pond
the farmer could then change their
behavior
in this way environmental indicators can
guide humans to make sustainable choices
another way humans can use environmental
indicators to make decisions about
natural resources is by monitoring
populations and estimating their growth
imagine that you have a pond in your
backyard
and let's imagine that you have searched
for all the correct environmental
indicators so you know the fish in your
pond are not suffering from pollution
one day you decide to go fishing
it might be tempting to fish as much as
you can so that you can invite all your
friends and have a big happy fish feast
but if you decided to take all the fish
out of the pond then there wouldn't be
any left to reproduce
so your feast next year would be pretty
sad
even if you just left a couple of fish
in the pool
they might not be able to reproduce
enough to replenish the population
other environmental factors might cause
the small fish population to go down
even further the fish might catch
diseases run out of food or end up being
some other creatures feast
there's some maximum number of fish that
you could take so that there's enough
fish left in the pond to reproduce and
replenish the population
this number is called the maximum
sustainable yield
basically you want to catch the most
fish to have the maximum yield
while still being sustainable
if you fish more than the maximum
sustainable yields then the fish will be
captured more quickly than they can
reproduce and the population will slowly
decline if you fish less than the
maximum sustainable yields then the fish
population will grow exponentially until
they reach the maximum capacity that the
ecosystem can support
some of the fish will eventually die
from density dependent factors like lack
of food and disease
on a bigger scale than your imaginary
pond natural resource managers try to
estimate what the maximum sustainable
yields will be each fishing season
this is why fishery managers regulate
the amount of certain types of fish each
fisher is allowed to catch per year
this is to make sure that next year we
will still have fish
so if we study the earth's ecosystems
and understand how we impact the
environment then we can find ways to
interact with ecosystems more
sustainably and really that's what
environmental science is all about